i can skate and you can film or
something
i'll catch it all let's do it
one of the first times i came to
california for a competition i was 14
and saw all like the girls that i had
looked up to and i guess that's kind of
the first time that i realized like
this is way cooler than i even thought
[Music]
so you're preparing for the olympics
you're born in texas grew up in hawaii
currently in san diego now you're going
to be going to tokyo did you ever think
that skateboarding would take you
that far definitely not was ever a
thought that really liked to make a
career out of it when i first started
skateboarding so
for now it to be the first year in the
olympics it's pretty crazy how far it's
come
this is you know the biggest competition
in the world so i want to be as ready as
possible
i'm very excited just to go to japan and
meet all the other athletes from so many
different sports and
watch them compete and learn from them
and have the whole olympic experience
okay so i'm thinking for a little follow
film line
as an nba player i go through tons of
emotions tons of
different types of training from
obviously regular season to the
postseason
for you going from kind of skating
around with your friends obviously
you metal at 17 you're in olympian at
22. how does your focus
training mindset shift as you prepare
for tokyo once you get into the actual
skating competition
i try to definitely keep my mindset
similar
you know keep it the same keep skating
keep doing it because i love it
that should never change in my opinion
it's a very lonely role because of the
sacrifices you have to make
to get there but once you do it's
definitely worth it
go that way a tiny bit now you're good
all right not moving here
i mean skateboarding has changed my life
you know you go to the skate park and
you don't just learn skateboarding you
learn
a million life lessons you learn to keep
getting up after you fall you
accept everyone doesn't matter if you're
good you're bad what race you are what
gender you are
we're all just here skateboarding and
we're all having fun and everyone
encourages everyone it's
not like any other sport bravo